Cuando comienzo charlas como ésta,
normalmente doy una explicación acerca de la sustentabilidad
porque muchas personas no saben qué es.
Ésta es una audiencia que sí lo sabe,
así que les daré la versión de 60 segundos. ¿De acuerdo?
Tengan paciencia. Lo haremos bien rápido, ¿saben?
Rellenen los espacios en blanco.
Bueno, ya saben, sustentabilidad, un planeta pequeño.
¿De acuerdo? Imaginen una Tierra pequeña, orbitando alrededor del Sol.
Ya saben, hace como un millón de años,
un montón de monos se cayeron de los árboles,
se volvieron un poco astutos, utilizaron el fuego,
inventaron la imprenta,
crearon el equipaje con ruedas.
Y construyeron la sociedad en la que vivimos hoy.
Desgraciadamente, a pesar de que esta sociedad es, sin lugar a dudas,
la más próspera y dinámica que el mundo jamás haya creado,
tiene algunas fallas muy, muy graves.
Una de ellas es que toda sociedad tiene una huella ecológica.
Tiene un impacto en el planeta que es medible.
Cuántas cosas pasan por tu vida,
cuántos residuos dejas.
Y nosotros, en este momento, en nuestra sociedad,
hemos alcanzado un nivel dramáticamente insustentable.
Estamos acabando con casi cinco planetas.
Si todos en el planeta vivieran como nosotros lo hacemos,
necesitaríamos entre cinco, seis, siete,
algunos dicen que hasta 10 planetas para sobrevivir.
Está claro que no tenemos 10 planetas.
De nuevo, ya saben, mental, visual, 10 planetas, un planeta,
10 planetas, un planeta. ¿De acuerdo?
No tenemos eso. Así que ése es un problema.
El segundo problema es que el planeta que tenemos
se está consumiendo de forma absolutamente injusta. ¿De acuerdo?
Los norteamericanos, como yo, ya saben,
somos básicamente como cerdos glotones, que se revuelcan,
y comemos toda clase de cosas.
Y luego, vas hacia el otro extremo
hacia la gente que vive en la región de Asia-Pacífico, o incluso más, África.
Y la gente sencillamente no tiene lo suficiente para sobrevivir.
Esto produce todo tipo de tensiones,
toda clase de dinámicas que son perturbadoras.
Y hay cada vez más personas así. ¿Verdad?
De modo que así es cómo lucirá el planeta en 20 años.
Será un lugar muy poblado, con al menos ocho mil millones de personas.
Y para hacer las cosas todavía más difíciles, el planeta es muy joven.
Un tercio de las personas son niños.
Y estos niños están creciendo de una manera completamente diferente
a como lo hacían sus padres, sin importar dónde vivan.
Han estado expuestos a esta idea de nuestra sociedad, de nuestra prosperidad.
Y puede que no quieran vivir exactamente como nosotros.
Puede que no quieran ser estadounidenses, o británicos,
o alemanes, o sudafricanos,
sino que quieran su propia versión
de una vida más próspera, y más dinámica,
y más, ya saben, agradable.
Y todas estas cosas se combinan para ejercer
una gran presión sobre el planeta.
Y si no podemos averiguar la forma de abordar esa tensión,
nos vamos a encontrar cada vez más pronto
enfrentándonos a situaciones que son simplemente impensables.
Todos en esta sala han escuchado los peores escenarios posibles.
No hace falta que hable de eso.
Pero voy a hacer esta pregunta, ¿cuál es la alternativa?
Y diré que, en este momento, la alternativa es inimaginable.
O sea, que de un lado tenemos lo impensable,
y del otro lo inimaginable.
Aún no sabemos cómo construir una sociedad
que sea medioambientalmente sustentable,
que sea compartible con todos en el planeta,
que promueva la estabilidad, la democracia y los derechos humanos,
y que sea alcanzable en el lapso de tiempo necesario
para superar los desafíos a los que nos enfrentamos.
Aún no sabemos cómo hacerlo.
¿Entonces qué es Worldchanging?
Bueno, pueden pensar que Worldchanging
es una agencia de noticias para el futuro inimaginable.
Es decir, lo que hacemos es buscar
ejemplos de herramientas, modelos e ideas,
que, si se adoptaran ampliamente, podrían cambiar el juego. ¿De acuerdo?
Muchas veces, cuando doy una charla como ésta, hablo sobre cosas
que estoy seguro de que todos en esta sala ya han escuchado,
pero la mayoría de la gente no.
Así que pensé hacer algo un poco distinto hoy,
y hablar sobre lo que buscamos, en vez de decirles, ya saben,
en vez de darles ejemplo ciertos y probados.
Hablar de las cosas que estamos vislumbrando.
Ofrecerles una pequeña mirada de nuestra agenda editorial.
Y dado que tengo 13 minutos para hacerlo, será algo rápido.
Así que, no sé, sólo quédense conmigo. ¿De acuerdo?
Así que, primero ¿qué estamos buscando? Ciudad verde brillante.
Una de las mayores palancas que tenemos en el mundo desarrollado
para cambiar el impacto que tenemos sobre el planeta
es cambiar el modo en que vivimos en las ciudades.
Ya somos un planeta urbano,
y eso es especialmente cierto en el mundo desarrollado.
Y las personas que viven en las ciudades del mundo desarrollado
suelen ser prósperas, y por eso consumen muchas cosas.
Si cambiamos la dinámica,
primero creando ciudades que sean más compactas y más habitables...
Aquí, por ejemplo, está Vancouver, una ciudad que si no han visitado,
deben hacerlo. Es una ciudad fabulosa.
Y están construyendo densidad, una nueva densidad,
mejor que nadie en el planeta en este momento.
Están logrando alentar a los norteamericanos para que no usen sus autos,
lo cual está genial.
Así que tienes densidad. También tienes gestión del crecimiento.
Dejas de lado lo natural para ser natural.
Esto es en Portland. Ésa es una urbanización real.
Esa tierra de ahí continuará siendo pasto siempre.
Han rodeado la ciudad con una línea.
Naturaleza, ciudad. Nada cambia.
Una vez que se hacen esas cosas, se pueden inciar todo tipo de inversiones.
Se puede empezar a hacer cosas como, ya saben,
sistemas de tránsito que realmente funcionen para transportar personas,
de formas efectivas y razonablemente cómodas. ¿De acuerdo?
También se puede empezar a cambiar lo que se construye.
Éste es el Beddington Zero Energy Development en Londres,
es uno de los edificios más eficientes del mundo. Es un lugar fabuloso.
Ahora podemos construir edificios que generan su propia electricidad,
que reciclan la mayor parte de su agua,
que son mucho más cómodos que los edificios tradicionales,
usan luz natural, etcétera, y a largo plazo cuestan menos.
Tejados ecológicos. Bill McDonough habló de eso anoche, así que no me ocuparé mucho de ello.
Pero ya que también hay personas que viven
cerca unas de otras,
una de las cosas que se puede hacer es,
con el desarrollo de las tecnologías de la información,
comenzar a tener lugares inteligentes.
Se puede comenzar a saber en qué lugar están las cosas.
Cuando se sabe dónde están las cosas, es más fácil compartirlas.
Y cuando se comparten, al final se consume menos.
Un gran ejemplo son los clubes para compartir el automóvil,
que están empezando a popularizarse en Estados Unidos,
y también lo han hecho en muchos lugares de Europa, y son un gran ejemplo.
Si son de los que conducen, ya saben, una vez por semana,
¿realmente necesitan su propio auto?
Otra cosa que la tecnología de la información nos permite hacer
es comenzar a descubrir cómo consumir menos
sabiendo, y monitorizando, la cantidad que realmente consumimos.
Aquí tenemos un cable que cuanta más energía se consume, más brilla,
lo cual en mi opinión es un concepto bastante bueno,
aunque creo que debería de funcionar al contrario,
cuanta menos energía consuma, más brille.
Pero, saben, podría haber una perspectiva aún más sencilla.
Podríamos simplemente volver a etiquetar las cosas.
Este interruptor que dice, por un lado, inundación repentina,
y por el otro, apagado.
También puede cambiar la forma en que construimos las cosas.
Éste es un edificio biomórfico.
Se inspira en las formas que adopta la vida.
Muchos de estos edificios son increíblemente bellos,
y también mucho más eficientes.
Éste es un ejemplo de biomimetismo,
que es algo que estamos empezando a buscar mucho más.
En este caso, tenemos un diseño de concha
que se utilizó para crear un nuevo tipo de ventilador, que es mucho más eficaz.
Están ocurriendo muchas de estas cosas, es realmente sorpendente.
Los aliento a buscar en Worldchanging si les interesa.
Estamos empezando a informar cada vez más sobre esto .
También existe el diseño neobiológico,
en el que cada vez más utilizamos la vida misma
y los procesos de la vida como parte de nuestra industria.
Ésta, por ejemplo, es un alga generadora de hidrógeno.
Así que tenemos un modelo en potencia, un modelo emergente
sobre cómo percibir las ciudades en las que vivimos,
y convertirlas en ciudades Verdes Brillantes.
Desgraciadamente, la mayor parte de las personas del planeta no vive en nuestras ciudades.
Viven en megaciudades emergentes de países en desarrollo.
Y hay una estadística que me gusta usar a menudo,
que dice que estamos añadiendo una ciudad de Seattle cada cuatro días,
una ciudad del tamaño de Seattle al planeta cada cuatro días.
Estaba dando una charla hace dos meses,
y esta persona, que había trabajado para la ONU, se me acercó
y bastante nervioso, dijo, mira,
tu dato está mal, completamente equivocado.
Es cada siete días.
Así que, estamos añadiendo una ciudad del tamaño de Seattle cada siete días,
y la mayoría de esas ciudades parecen más esto que la ciudad en la que vivimos.
Muchas de esas ciudades están creciendo increíblemente rápido.
No tienen una infraestructura previa,
tienen un enorme número de personas que luchan contra la pobreza,
y un enorme número de personas están intentando encontrar
una forma diferente de hacer las cosas. ¿De acuerdo?
Así que ¿qué debemos hacer para que las megaciudades
de los países en desarrollo sean megaciudades Verdes Brillantes?
Bueno, lo primero que tenemos que hacer es superar fases.
Y ésta es una de las cosas que buscamos en todas partes.
La idea que hay detrás de superar fases es que
si eres una persona, o un país, que está atascado en una situación
en la que no tienes las herramientas y tecnologías que necesitas,
no hay razón para que inviertas en tecnología de última generación. ¿De acuerdo?
Que te viene mucho mejor, en términos casi universales,
buscar una versión de la nueva tecnología de bajo costo, o adaptada localmente.
Un caso con el que estamos familiarizados es con los celulares. ¿De acuerdo?
En todos los países en desarrollo, la gente se está pasando a los celulares,
saltando la etapa de las líneas fijas.
Si hay líneas fijas en muchos países en desarrollo,
normalmente son sistemas muy malos que se averían con frecuencia,
y cuestan grandes sumas de dinero. ¿Bien?
Así que prefiero esta imagen de aquí.
En particular me gusta el Ganesh del fondo, hablando por teléfono celular.
Cada vez tenemos más celulares, cuyo uso se está extendiendo en la sociedad.
Hemos escuchado todo sobre este tema aquí esta semana,
así que no diré mucho más, lo que sí diré es que,
lo que es válido para los celulares es válido para todo tipo de tecnologías.
Lo segundo son herramientas para la colaboración,
ya sean sistemas de colaboración, o sistemas de propiedad intelectual
que incentiven la colaboración. ¿Bien?
Cuando la gente tiene la capacidad para colaborar de forma libre e innovadora,
se obtienen diferentes tipos de soluciones.
Y esas soluciones son accesibles de una forma distinta
para las personas que carecen de capital. ¿Bien?
Así que, ya saben, tenemos software de código abierto,
tenemos Creative Commons y otros tipos de soluciones Copyleft. ¿De acuerdo?
Y esas cosas llevan a cosas como ésta.
Éste es un Telecentro en Sao Paulo.
Es un programa bastante notable
que utiliza software libre y de código abierto, máquinas baratas y hackeadas,
y fundamentalmente edificios abandonados...
ha unido una serie de centros comunitarios
donde la gente puede ir, obtener acceso a Internet de alta velocidad,
aprender técnicas de programación de forma gratuita.
Hoy en día, un cuarto de millón de personas lo utiliza cada año en Sao Paulo.
Y ese cuarto de millón de personas son los más pobres de Sao Paulo.
Me gusta especialmente el pequeño pingüino Linux al fondo.
Una de las cosas que está provocando es esta especie de explosión cultural sureña.
Y una de las cosas que nos interesa muchísimo en Worldchanging
son las formas en las que el sur se está redefiniendo,
y recategorizando a sí mismo
y que cada vez tienen menos que ver con la mayoría de nostros en esta sala.
O sea, que Bollywood no sólo está contestando a Hollywood. ¿Bien?
La música brasileña no sólo está contestando a los grandes sellos.
Está haciendo algo nuevo. Están ocurriendo cosas nuevas.
Hay interacción entre ellos. Y se logran cosas sorprendentes.
Como, no sé si alguno de ustedes ha visto la película "Ciudad de Díos"
Sí, es una película fabulosa si aún no la han visto.
Y trata sobre esta pregunta, de una forma muy artística e indirecta.
Tenemos otros ejemplos radicales
en los que se promociona la capacidad para usar herramientas culturales.
Éstas son personas que han sido visitadas por
el libromóvil de Internet en Uganda.
Y que están agitando sus primeros libros en el aire,
me parece que es una fotografía bastante buena.
También se facilita que la gente se pueda reunir
y actuar en su propio beneficio de forma cívica y política.
En formas que antes no se han dado.
Y como escuchamos anoche, como escuchamos al inicio de la semana,
son absolutamente vitales para facilitar la creación de nuevas soluciones,
tenemos que elaborar nuevas realidades políticas.
Y personalmente diré que debemos crear nuevas realidades políticas,
no sólo en lugares como la India, Afganistan, Kenia, Paquistán,
sino también aquí en casa.
Otro mundo es posible.
Un gran lema del movimiento antiglobalización. ¿Bien?
Lo retorcemos mucho.
Hablamos sobre cómo otro mundo no es posible, el otro mundo está aquí.
Que no es sólo que tengamos que imaginar
que exista una posibilidad vaga y diferente,
sino que tenemos que empezar a actuar un poco más en esa posibilidad.
Tenemos que empezar a hacer cosas como Lula, el presidente de Brasil.
¿Cuántas personas conocían a Lula antes de hoy?
Bastante mejor que una audiencia media, se lo puedo asegurar.
Así que Lula, está lleno de problemas, lleno de contradicciones,
pero una de las cosas que está haciendo es,
proponer una idea sobre cómo articular las relaciones internacionales
que cambia por completo el equilibrio del diálogo norte-sur hasta ahora
en una nueva forma de colaboración global.
Me gustaría que se fijaran en este amigo.
Otro ejemplo de esta especie de segundo superpoder
es la aparición de estos juegos que se denominan serios.
Estamos observándolo mucho. Se está extendiendo por todos sitios.
Esta captura de pantalla es de "A Force More Powerful".
"A Force More Powerful" es un videojuego en el que,
mientras juegas, te enseña cómo involucrarse
en una insurrección no violenta y un cambio de régimen.
Aquí hay otra. Ésta es de un juego llamado "Food Force",
un juego que les enseña a los niños a cómo gestionar un campo de refugiados.
Todas estas cosas están contribuyendo de una forma muy dinámica
a un enorme incremento, especialmente en los países en desarrollo,
del interés y de la pasión de la gente por la democracia.
Obtenermos tan pocas noticias de los países en desarrollo,
que algunas veces olvidamos que hay literalmente
millones de personas luchando por cambiar las cosas
por ser más justos, libres, democráticos, menos corruptos.
Y, saben, no escuchamos esas historias lo suficiente.
Pero está ocurriendo en todas partes,
y estas herramientas en parte lo están posibilitando.
Ahora cuando se suman todas esas cosas,
cuando se suman el hecho de superar fases y el uso de nuevas herramientas,
saben, el segundo superpoder, etcétera, ¿qué se obtiene?
Bien, rápidamente, se obtiene un futuro Verde Brillante para los países en desarrollo.
Se obtiene, por ejemplo, distribución de energía verde por todo el mundo.
Se obtiene... éste es un edificio en Hyderabad, India.
Es el edificio más eficiente del mundo.
Se obtienen soluciones locales, cosas que funcionan
para la gente que carece de capital o tiene un acceso limitado.
Se obtienen ingenieros solares descalzos transportando paneles solares a montañas remotas.
Se obtiene acceso a la medicina a distancia.
Son enfermeras indias aprendiendo a usar PDAs
para acceder a bases de datos que tienen información
a la que no tienen acceso a distancia desde sus casas .
Se obtienen nuevas herramientas para la gente de los países en desarrollo.
Éstas son luces LED que ayudan a casi mil millones de personas,
para quienes el anochecer significa oscuridad,
a tener nuevos medios para operar.
Éstos son refrigeradores que no requieren de electricidad,
son un diseño de olla dentro de otra olla.
Y se obtienen soluciones para el agua. El agua es uno de los problemas más urgentes.
Aquí tenemos un diseño para almacenar agua de lluvia que es super barato
y fácil de conseguir para la gente de los países en desarrollo.
Aquí tenemos un diseño para destilar agua usando luz solar.
Aquí un atrapa niebla, que, si vives en un área húmeda, como la jungla,
destilará agua limpia y potable del aire.
Aquí tenemos una forma de transportar agua.
Me encanta, saben... me refiero a que cargar agua es una lata,
y a alguien se le ocurrió la idea de, bueno, y si la enrollas. ¿Bien?
Me refiero a que es un gran diseño.
Ésta es una fabulosa invención, LifeStraw.
Básicamente succionas el agua a través de ella
y se convierte en potable para cuando llega a los labios.
Es decir, personas que estén en situaciones desesperadas pueden tener esto.
Ésta es una de mis cosas Worldchanging favoritas.
Es un carrusel inventado por la compañía Roundabout,
que bombea agua mientras los niños juegan. ¿Saben?
En serio... échenle una mano, es bastante bueno.
Y lo mismo para las personas que están en crisis absoluta. ¿De acuerdo?
Esperamos tener un incremento de 200 millones de refugiados para el año 2020
debido al cambio climático y la inestabilidad política.
¿Cómo ayudamos a esas personas?
Bueno, hay todo tipo de sorprendentes diseños humanitarios
que están siendo desarrollados de formas colaborativas en todo el planeta.
Algunos de esos diseños incluyen modelos para actuar,
como nuevos modelos de enseñanza en medio de los campos de refugiados.
Nuevos modelos de pedagogía para desplazados.
Y tenemos nuevas herramientas.
Ésta es sin lugar a dudas uno de mis favoritas.
¿Alguien sabe qué es esto?
Audiencia: Detecta minas terrestres.
Exactamente, es una flor detectora de minas terrestres.
Si vives en uno de estos lugares
donde aproximadamente medio millón de minas sin detectar se encuentra disperso,
puedes arrojar estas semillas al campo.
Y al crecer, crecerán alrededor de las minas,
sus raíces detectarán los productos químicos en ellas,
y donde las flores se vuelvan rojas no pisas.
Sí, semillas que pueden salvar tu vida. ¿Saben?
(Aplausos)
También me encanta porque me parece que
el ejemplo, las herramientas que usamos para cambiar el mundo,
deben de ser bellas por sí mismas.
Saben, eso no es suficiente para sobrevivir.
Tenemos que hacer algo mejor que lo que tenemos.
Y creo que lo haremos.
Sólo para terminar, en las inmortales palabras de H.G. Wells,
creo que cosas mejores están en camino.
Creo que, de hecho, "todo el pasado no es más que el principio de un principio.
Todo lo que la mente humana ha logrado
no es más que el sueño antes del despertar".
Espero que eso resulte ser verdad.
La gente en esta sala me ha dado más confianza que nunca de que así ocurrirá.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)